fact the internet loves Kim Kardashian  her mobile game Kim Kardashian Hollywood  has already made over a hundred million  dollars for developer Glu Mobile so it  makes sense that the company has just  launched another game based on Kim  sisters-in-law Kendall and Kylie Jenner  the game simply titled Kendall and Kylie  tasks players with going viral and  building an Internet fanbase thanks to  the girls ages the game aims for a  younger audience than Kim's game and  it's working it's currently the number  one free app not bad for two girls who  aren't even old enough to drink Kendall  and Kylie can be downloaded from Google  Play and the app store for free but  there are plenty of in-game purchases if  that's your thing and if the celebrity  life isn't your thing at all don't worry  for all the best video game news and  reviews you're already in the right  place  you